every villain has his day oh right it's
Sunday which means Doctor Who and it
also means that it's time for me to get
to Big Finish and these are voted on by
my patreon supporters which one I'm
gonna do next and they've selected that
I cover Davros
and this is the story featuring The
Sixth Doctor Colin Baker this kind of
rounds out what is sort of a thematic
trilogy if not a narrative trilogy of
villain centric stories because and I
had done previously master and Omega and
master featured Seventh Doctor Omega
featured the fifth doctor so now I get
to cover
Davros now Davros as a character is yeah
I like him
in a lot of ways at least as far as his
time on the show goes I find him a
little over loved at times I like him
any works especially for his part you
know in the creation of the Daleks but I
kind of resent the character a little
bit for at least in the classic era kind
of taking over the Dalek stories after
he was introduced in Genesis the Daleks
it was really rare to have a Dalek story
that was not also a Davros story so he
kind of co-opted their entire narrative
which I never really appreciated because
I liked him as a character I would have
been really interested to see what was
going on with the Daleks separate from
him especially considering that he
didn't he he wasn't really their leader
he didn't really have control over them
which was an interesting dynamic but
that always kind of bugged me and also
comparatively we I'm at least in the
show we've gotten very little time with
Davros separate from the Daleks now he
still has good moments he has good
highlights I do actually really love the
stuff with him in the which is familiar
and I think Julian bleach or
sorry plays him really well in you know
in modern era but here we have Terry
Malloy I'm playing him from classic era
Davros
and so this is uh this this is more in
line with the classic stuff and nicely
it is separate from the Daleks so he's
not co-opting a Dalek story and he's not
shackled with the Daleks
so basic plot overview and synopsis I'll
try and avoid spoilers because I know
not as many people listen to the audios
as watch the show so I can't count on
most of my audience already knowing this
thing so plot wise the way it goes is
Davros and this has kind of already been
established in the show by this point
because Davros actually dies at the very
end of his first appearance and then
keeps coming back and it gets
established and and sort of firmed up
here that his the life support functions
of his chair you know that he uses to
get around because he's severely
disfigured and disabled has it's got
really phenomenal life support system so
he's as long as he's in that chair he's
almost impossible to kill so he is his
body is stolen by this head of a global
or not global like galactic level
company and I don't think they actually
say a year this takes place in but it's
it's sort of your generic unspecified
future where human society because we
they are explicitly called out as humans
it's not an alien society human society
is run by a handful of corporations it's
it's effectively implied that there
isn't really government anymore and that
capitalism is such that you know the
corporations are just running everything
at this point and you got and you get
your usual sort of dystopia elements
associated with that as one would expect
with that kind of setup but the the head
of one of these corporations and his
wife they steal what they think is
Davros as ba
so they kind of get a bit of bonus when
he comes around and they're able to
revive him now they're interested in him
for different reasons the the company
owner sees him as a general asset
especially once he's awake because then
he's like I can use this man's mind
because he was a brilliant scientist and
I can develop new tactics new ways of
coming at things new products new ways
to increase efficiency all this stuff
and then there's his wife who is a
historian and has had a very heavy
interest in the Daleks and Davros so she
sort of has that that I was gonna say
academic but it's more than academic
with her she has a very keen specific
interest in Davros and so there's that
now the doctor gets brought into this
fairly coincidentally which you know it
happens sometimes
so he gets brought in by a journalist
who is trying to uncover stuff about
this corporation and the doctor
initially just doesn't want to get
involved because he doesn't like this is
just the capitalist system and you know
the big threat that what the journalist
is trying to uncover is something that
will lead to a whole bunch of people
losing their jobs and Minds getting shut
down and the doctor doesn't not care but
that's that's real small potatoes by his
usual scale of stepping in to intervene
so he's a bit reluctant but he's kind of
okay but then he sees Davros as or as
like whoa hold on and obviously that
completely changes the game and
throughout this we get flashback
sequences of Davros before he was
disfigured and you know put in the
debilitated state we are used to seeing
him with so we get flashbacks to his
time with the Khaled people you know in
their war with the falls as he attempts
to you know work on things to help them
win the
war he has a relationship with a with a
woman that becomes an end to end up
being a big part of that and I want to
go too much more into the plot
specifically beyond that well I will say
is this this story attempts to do
something that I think is really
dangerous and I mean that mostly
narrative Lee but also a little bit not
just that with how things have been
going lately in the world and what I
mean by that is it takes us to a certain
degree it humanizes Davros more than
we've gotten in the past and there's a
couple of reasons that that's kind of a
dangerous thing to do the first is that
you know narrative Lee you can end up
defanging you know a villain I think a
humanized villain it can be a great film
but especially a villain that you've had
long-running starting 2d human it's
starting to humanize them more and give
more of a reason for people to have
sympathy with them can very easily make
them less effective as a villain or make
writers less willing to use them at the
at the same level of villainy so I was
worried about that and then in regards
to Davos specifically given the links of
the Daleks in fact the eteri nation
created them to very explicitly be a
parallel to the Nazis in fact that
Davros himself is he's a little bit of a
Mengele figure to humanize someone like
that that's that's I could be really
distasteful to do but thankfully it
threads the needle really expertly
because we get little glimpses of
basically how down Ross's mind works
because his whole mental process his way
of approaching and looking at things he
has to have you know he when he's
revived he's looking at you know these
machines and these things and he's
understanding most of the technology or
at least the theory behind it almost a
mean
because he's that smart but there's core
basic fundamental concepts that he just
can't he has trouble wrapping his head
around he needs laid out for him you
know things like the nature of a
capitalistic society to be honest the
idea of developing things for profit
whereas he he lived his entire like the
the calzone the Thals were at war from
before he was born so he lives his
entire life and he was raised in a
military mindset in a what is most
effective for our side to help defeat
the other side he is his entire thought
process is a we are at war thought
process and that gets illustrated really
well across this and in regards to what
I said about the danger of kind of
basically humanizing a monster
especially one that is partially
inspired by real-life monsters this
actually this actually manages to kind
of highlight why that's a problem with
with the white figure who like I said
kind of idolizes him to a certain degree
because she is it's never explicitly
stated as such which is nice because it
respects the the intelligence of the
audience but she is painted a little bit
as a Dalek apologist a bit like a modern
era Nazi apologists would you know the
people who say okay look yes they did
bad things but let's focus on you know
all the good things and not that you
know it's necessarily a good thing to
paint you know anybody group or anything
with the they're always evil that's the
end of conversation brush but at the
same time to to focus exclusively on
what you think are the positives you can
see she has come to idolize a monster
like a true monster that she sees as a
great man and it's kind of unnerving and
it's depicted as unnerving which again I
think was a real good way for them to
basically address the potential elephant
in the room and defuse what
have been a very uncomfortable situation
as far as what the story is doing and in
regards to the revelations we get about
Davros everything lines up really well
so we get a little humanizing moments
but then as we get more of his backstory
more of his thought process and what
he's after it all lines up so it's not
like oh this we're not seeing the human
behind the monster you know that we have
been seen before we are seeing the human
components that exist in what is still
undeniably a monster and it also deals
nicely with whether or not Davros is
capable of changing and I would consider
this aspire but I mean Davros comes back
and other stories so we know this isn't
it for him but yeah altom utley he can't
but what I like about this is it doesn't
do what the lazy thing would have been
the lazy thing would have been that he's
presenting a facade to you know this
corporate head and and his wife and
going acting as if he's going to change
while planning and scheming behind the
scenes and that's not really what goes
on he does try he does try to put his
mind to the problems that are presented
to him you know problems of
overpopulation of insufficient resources
he does try to put his mind towards
solving things that were never a problem
on Skaro they didn't have an
overpopulation problem people died
really young in the war so like these
are things he's never had to deal with
that he does try to put his mind to
solving these things but just because of
the way he's wired and I don't mean that
like in a mental illness way I mean
because of just the angle and the
mentality that he comes at problems he
even wanting to he can't change enough
he's going to fall back on what makes
the most sense to him and what makes the
most sense to him is war is destruction
is you can't make anything that's worth
a darn until you tear
everything else that I was already here
down that's that's just fundamentally
who he is but I like that it wasn't a
haha I was scheming this the whole time
cuz that would be really cheap and lazy
and it also would have reinforced you
know that because I brought this up on
the the two doctors not long ago with
the doctor you know seeming like oh
these people they're evil and like it's
a race an alien race that we had never
seen before and that struck me is really
odd and you know with the six doctors
saying the same thing about Davros while
it's certainly more earned with taverts
he's he's got personal history with the
guy he can back up what he's saying at
the same time at any time the doctor is
making an argument of no they're just
evil
if the I really need the story to handle
that delicately because that puts me
again in a bit of discomfort because
that's not a position I like the doctor
taking you know condemning somebody
forever in perpetuity saying that
there's no way that they can change but
here because it's it's not really like I
and he was right to doubt Davros it's
more of a case of look Davros tried and
the doctor was right but not in a he
will never change but just that he he
can't and so it sort of it allows the
doctor to keep his moral high ground
while even while espousing you know what
he is about being faded to be awful
which Davros kind of is so I think this
was I was just really well put together
and as far as the performances go Terry
Malloy is awesome as Davros he's really
good and he gets to stretch his legs a
little bit in terms of the different
layers and levels he's able to do he's
able to give a surprisingly nuanced
performance of Davros even you know the
the current era Davros to say nothing of
the flashbacks when he doesn't even have
you know the modulated voice RNA the
rest of it and there's way less of the
screaming Davros
in this then I because that can grate on
me and there was not nearly as much as I
was afraid that was gonna be so having
this all play out the way it said oh and
call them baked come Baker's really good
I'm really coming to enjoy Sixth Doctor
audio adventures which is nice because I
really have not enjoyed his his stints
on the show like at all so it's really
nice to know that I can come to Big
Finish and go oh it's a Sixth Doctor
story and feel good about that as
opposed to feel dread about that so it's
really nice and there's no companion in
this one I mean there are people helping
the doctor but he's companion free in
this particular story so he and Terry
Malloy are very much the main focus and
all the supporting characters are fine
but it really is this this is Deb this
is Davros as story more than anybody
else is certainly more than the doctors
or any of the supporting characters and
it's it's nicely done I think it's
probably the best done of of these three
villain centric ones out of master Omega
Davros I think Davros was the best one
then master and then Omega now all three
are good none of these are bad but
that's just the order that I will put
them in if I were to rank them but all
three are worth listening to this is
this is great stuff and I don't know
what was gonna be the next big finish
that my patrons have for me to do we'll
see I haven't had that poll yet at time
of recording but in any case
have you heard Davros what are your
thoughts on if you haven't heard about
it what are your thoughts on the
character in general whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's a bunch of
stuff to do and I think you know what
most of it is because you know there's
buttons and there's links and there's
all sorts of stuff down there check it
out if you like just link to the patreon
and so just remember folks you're the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]